Hello, I'm Daven Hiskey, you're watching the
TodayIFoundOut YouTube channel.
In the video today, we're looking at how clownfish
managed to breed, despite that they're all
born male.
Let's get started.
Clownfish, also known as anemonefish, are
sequential hermaphrodites that first develop
into males.
In fact, they live in regimented schools made
up of all males and just one female- the lone
female being the dominant and generally the
largest fish in a given group.
The second in command of the school is usually
the largest, and most aggressive, male of
the group.
Due to his dominance of the other males, he'll
tend to ensure they stay small via taking
the best food opportunities for himself and
the like.
Besides the perks of more food, he's also
the only one that gets to breed with the female.
During breeding, the female will lay sometimes
thousands of eggs, depending on the species
and her size, usually on a pre-cleaned rock
or coral close to the anemone she lives in.
After the eggs are laid, the male will go
along and fertilize them.
From here, if a given egg is poor quality,
whether damaged (i.e.
Nemo) or it becomes infected by a fungus or
the like, the male will typically eat the
egg.
Likewise, if the egg is infertile, or if the
clownfish is an inexperienced breeder or stressed,
he may also simply eat the eggs.
Otherwise, the male, and rarely the female,
will guard the fish for the 6-10 days it takes
to hatch, as well as regularly fan them, which
increases the chances of the eggs successfully
developing.
After the eggs hatch, the parent's job is
done and they have nothing to do with the
baby fish, who ascend to the surface and feed
on plankton until maturation.
If the female dies, the dominate male will
get first choice of food and begin to gain
weight, ultimately becoming female.
She will then choose a breeding partner among
the available males, which is usually the
largest and most aggressive male available.
At the same time, everyone else moves up one
in the pecking order.
The two will pair off and breed together until
something happens to one or the other, at
which point the cycle begins again.
It is thought that this peculiar ability to
change sex developed because, unlike many
other types of fish, clownfish almost never
stray very far away from their homes in sea
anemones, which they form a symbiotic relationship
with.
Thus, if not for their ability to adapt to
potentially limited mating partners in their
local area, they may not get a chance to breed
at all.
And while we're on the topic of Finding Nemo
related facts, you might be interested to
know that whales do not blow water out of
their blowholes.
Further, the whale’s trachea doesn’t connect
to the esophagus of the whale; so when Dory
and Marlin went down the whale’s throat,
in real life, they’d have simply been eaten.
You might at this point be wondering then
why it looks like whales do blow water out.
We've covered this in great detail in this
video, but briefly, when the whale resurfaces,
they have to release the used up air back
into the atmosphere just like all other mammals
do.
This does result in a spout, but it isn’t
ocean water.
The air inside the whale is typically quite
warm from the whale’s body heat.
When it’s exhaled, it meets the much cooler
temperature of the air outside and immediately
condenses, making it look like a spout of
water.
(This air is also often mixed with mucus —it
is a nose, after all!)
Another interesting thing to note is that,
as a rule, baleen whales—those whales who
don’t have teeth, but rather have baleen
plates to filter food out of the water—
like the one depicted on Finding Nemo, have
two blowholes, while toothed whales have just
one.
Types of baleen whales include the blue, gray,
and humpback whales, the latter of which was
the one depicted in Finding Nemo, even though
it was shown with just one blowhole.
Another whale of an error in Finding Nemo
is when they depict the humpback whale as
having a uvula- whales don’t have those.
So thanks for watching this video, if you
liked it, please click that like button below
and consider sharing it with anyone you think
might be interested.
And of course if you’re new to TodayIFoundOut,
don’t forget to click the subscribe button
to get more interesting videos like this.
We release a new video almost every single
day, so you’re sure to find something you
find interesting.
Thanks for watching.